[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I can make them do what I want happy
Monday everybody from Scenic New York
Now's the Time of Year where leaves
start to fall on the homeless people
and along with the smells of skunk weed
and rotting drug addicts the sidewalks
have added seasonably appropriate
pumpkin spice urine oh my God Autumn is
in the air in a few weeks electric car
fires will keep people warm
but as a new election approaches that
must mean it's hunting season
[Music]
accusations
it's so easy
[Music]
and Christy knows I do it's the Time of
the Season
[Music]
pretty good Gene awesome but you know
we're not talking about hunting for deer
or expired health and beauty products at
Dollar General
no it's political dissident season you
know those awful people who hold views
that make so-called tolerant media
Elites shriek like you told them their
kids going to a trade school
a gentle a gentle chuckle from the
audience
it's now any non-liberal in the public
eye the season opened with a direct shot
at two women Lauren bobert and Christy
gnome two major Republican gilfs
what's that I'm glad you asked
[Music]
grannies I'd love
to friend
what did you think it stood for
you people are dirtier than Hunter
Biden's bed sheets
yeah disgusting now these two have got
to be the hottest grannies since that
Minx is still Getty
man was she wild I'll never forget that
weekend in Reno
Bingo slot machines intercourse
sorry
but think about the contrast between
Republican grannies and liberal ones on
the right you got Norman bober who are
hot as balls
and more fun than Joy Behar and
blackface juggling Donuts on a unicycle
oh
over on the left however the grannies
tend to look more like this
I hate it when my grandmother pees
standing up
anyway in Denver last week gilf number
one bobert a sitting U.S congresswoman
showed those sitting skills by sitting
in the audience of a performance of
Beetlejuice
and no it wasn't about The Life and
Times of Lori Lightfoot
like beetle Beetlejuice if you say
bobert's name three times you'll summon
some cleavage
laughs
apparently she Vaped and talked too much
throughout the performance too much for
the Management's liking wait you're not
supposed to vape and talk in a theater
tell that to the audience at a Tyler
Perry movie
[Music]
the bird and her date also got a little
touchy feely and were then asked to
leave
and suddenly we had a news of Bruder
film especially when he moved his hands
back and to the left
see I knew they wouldn't get that
producer
I told you they weren't gonna get it
last time I ever listened to these
people anyway the media act as if it was
the worst thing to happen in a theater
since the Lincoln assassination because
she showed you you don't need to visit
the concession stand to grab some
Whoppers
now to me Bo Burr looks like a lot of
fun even if she should stick to musicals
like Beauty and the breast or the loin
king or
Fiddler on my boob
[Laughter]
but view alumni Megan McCain tweeted
that bobert is trash
adding what all the Liberals were saying
that children might have been nearby and
they would have been scarred for life
after all no one attends musical theater
and expects to see a man who's attracted
to women
laughs
yeah but that possibility is true of
anywhere you might hook up right not all
of us are like Hunter and get Daddy to
pay for rooms at the Chateau Marmont
has since apologized so South Dakota
Governor Christie gnome was next on The
Hit List apparently the notion that
gnome and former Trump something or
rather Corey Lewandowski or dating is a
matter of international significance
after all South Dakota is a state known
for drilling
now even I admit this is an amazing
story
it is because if true how Corey
Lewandowski managed this one is
something an MIT research team should
look into on behalf of all men who
appear to resemble a meerkat with a crew
cut
it's true
no offense
but it's weird considering Obama's
letters admitting that he fantasized
about men were all but ignored by the
Press
or how about how the liberal media
treats Hunter here's the cliff notes
version It's just wrong to go after
Hunter his daddy loves him so much and
he's in recovery right and he only hired
those hookers to give Joe's Corvette a
wax job
but these people they're the pervs if
they were in Epstein's Client List then
we'd have it it is Rich coming from a
party that wants your son to be prom
queen and your daughter King
and sorry you gotta admit bobert looks
way better in a party dress than this
guy
the point all those on the right who
communicate well who might have some
influence are suddenly being targeted
Joe Rogan Russian agent Tulsi gabbard
Tucker Carlson hell even RFK Jr just for
being a moderate
and the biggest game of all is the great
orange Buffalo Trump himself
the left brought in its big game Hunters
using seasoned prosecutors to try to bag
him I do wonder about jail time I bet he
doesn't even think about it
I don't even think about it
I'm built a little differently I guess
because I have had people come up to me
and say how do you do it sir how do you
do it I don't even think about it don't
even think about it what a strategy
after all being unable to think has
worked wonders for Democrats
yeah
now for long time viewers of this show
you may realize that everyone being
hunted by the media have one thing in
common
bobert gnome Trump they were all guests
on Gutfeld which makes me wonder is that
why some people won't come on the show
hell even Carrot Top turns us down
constantly Carrot Top
so if Stallone Schwarzenegger in
Eastwood too for real even a tough guy
like John Wayne won't do our show
the least he could do is return our
calls
but all of this is worth asking one
thing well this strategy of targeting
actually work well who knows but you can
bet if my ratings get any higher they'll
say I killed Mother Teresa
pick it up a notch let's welcome
tonight's guests no one can write
sitcoms like him because they're on
strike TV writer and producer Roblox
her mouth shuts down twice a day because
of overheating oh so the true Fox True
Crime podcast Emily Campagna
he teaches creative writing so maybe he
can save tonight's Show comedian and
author of that joke isn't funny anymore
Lou Perez
oh
and finally she's never been used as a
before model New York Times best
contributor
you know what I love about you rob long
don't stop right there
you always look like you're a guest star
on uh The Love Boat right
you're you're gonna walk up to Captain
Stu being and he's telling them who who
I am you play a recently widowed mystery
author and you end up hooking up with a
widower Florence Henderson right yes but
it turns out I'm an international jewel
thief yes exactly yeah and Ted Lang
who plays the bartender wrestles you to
the ground oh wow that yeah that's
another movie actually yeah yeah so
we're talking about this The Green Room
why is it that Republican grannies are
hotter than liberal left-wing grannies
we were talking about this at length uh
it's so it's a trend that I've noticed
like all Republican conservative women
are just hotter when they're older is
because they were hotter when they were
younger
I I don't I don't know how to answer
this question and not be canceled
instantly uh except I have to say I was
surprised that bobert was a grandmother
she looks really great for a grandmother
yeah yeah yeah and she's only 25. okay
that's another problem that's an
additional concern to bring up uh I'm
not quite sure I know why that is I
think that probably I think they're for
a lot of Republican women they're uh
their activity in politics came late in
their life right they actually had a
career they did other stuff they kind of
come to it kind of as you know Lauren
bober was sort of a citizen activist I
mean I'm not necessarily a fan
politically these people but they they
came from something from The Real World
and I think in the real world you kind
of like try to look your best you know
that's a really that's a really good
point I'm surprised yeah that you came
up with it because normally you don't
yeah usually your first answer kind of
meanders a little bit do you think that
she's getting a bet Beau Bert's getting
a bad break for what happened in that
theater yeah a little bit I mean I think
I mean first of all it was kind of look
I feel like if you're the kind of person
that wants to go to the theater and vape
and kind of get frisky with your date
it's probably best not to ever talk
about sort of who's moral and who should
go to church and who shouldn't it's
something it's not you said yeah what
man said that that one right there
that's not to bring it up and you don't
have to bring it up these are not
necessary things for American policy you
could be a conservative and not
necessarily have to tell people that you
go to church more I think you're wrong
and I'll tell you why every place that
you hook up there's a potential for
children around that is your Kink not
anybody else
Emily uh any theories on the granny
hotness close to you now that it gets
real yes
any theories on granny hotness or would
you like to address the boat
situation or the Chris
station what is Corey Lewandowski have
and don't use your hands
[Laughter]
um you know I don't I don't know about
that part yeah but I I I do think
um you know I see truths in both so I
absolutely see what is clearly a kill
the Beast occurring from the left right
um however you can argue that you know
the point about public figures is that
even if she's acting in her private
capacity the whole point is you are
never off you are always representing
who you are working for when you have a
job like that and when you do anything
in a public place we all have to know
now that of course it's being filmed
that's the whole point so I thought her
apologies were very well worded it's
unfortunate that she had to walk back
some of her initial denials
um I think that her constituency and her
followers are very loyal for her but I
see the mistake frankly as a rookie
mistake that's the whole point again we
all know that you're always being filmed
in public places and if you want to go
up and get hot and steep well that's a
felony
her boyfriend is a Democrat who owns a
gay are yeah yeah so I mean clearly
she's quite tolerant Lou you know what
no this wouldn't have been an issue if
they were drag queens in front of a
classroom right
yeah I mean uh I I have two kids a
two-year-old and a three-year-old and so
anytime my wife and I are getting it on
there are always kids somewhere nearby
waiting to ruin the moment for us so
it's like you know you think you're in a
safe place you have Beetlejuice up there
that incredible cinematic turn to get
theatrical thing and then the lights are
down and then uh yeah and you know quite
frankly look I'm a gentleman and I think
that the man should have done all the
apologizing because he was doing all of
the work yes as you can see
yeah don't you think here's the theory
do you think that there are a lot of
people that were just they don't like
seeing people who can't keep their hands
off each other because it doesn't
existing yeah yeah because the enduring
a relationship that's been in their
third decade and they're like get that
out of my face and it's like it's fresh
100 yeah
yes that's why I cannot watch like
R-rated films
I don't know Lou you're just gonna let
me die here aren't you die I'm wondering
like are we being filmed right now
because my fed my fetish is watching him
die
right now
that's great
[Laughter]
um I would just because you're new here
just keep your kids away from Greg
oh strange man from The Love Boat
you were
again we're trying to point out the
hypocrisy but
hypocritical about what bober did she
was having a little fun and you made out
in theaters yeah but I don't here's the
thing of course you know like I went to
high school
um so I think that I don't care what
anybody does in their personal life but
Lauren bobert does care what other
people do in their personal life so the
personal life is in public education can
I talk yeah let me know nope nope nope
of course okay thank you so much
engaging in conversation so a lot of
people have pointed out the hypocrisy oh
she's constantly going on and on about
how drag queens being around children is
sexualizing them and grooming them when
she's doing foreplay in the theater
where there could be kids around and I
agree with that I also think there's
another way to look at it which is if
you watch this video it totally makes
sense why she thinks all of these things
are so sexual because look how sexual
she finds Beetlejuice the musical
thank you
why are they making are they going to
run out of movies for musicals I mean I
mean when you're mad when you're you're
really scraping the bottle of the bottom
of the barrel if you're doing
Beetlejuice she seems like she loved it
yeah they got to do Texas Chainsaw
Massacre the musical
that's probably happening right now by
the way
[Laughter]
I think the reason you're
looking to get this is because you're
nervous about this but I can put your
just set your mind at ease just remember
you are in no danger of this happening
as you have no discernible genitalia
nobody likes the truth bomb hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else